listen majors are great obviously but
there's a tournament that holds a
special place in the hearts of cs fans
katowice
yes this past weekend the spodex saw a
new champion crowned a new challenger
emerge
and one of the most heartfelt speeches
in esports history delivered
it was an incredible weekend that we
won't soon forget but even though the
goat didn't pick up any silverware i
think it's fair to say that his
contribution may have been even more
important let's dive in
[Music]
hey guys before we get into the video i
just wanted to remind you to subscribe
to the channel turn on notifications and
leave a like if you enjoyed the video it
really does help and i love doing
counter strike content on this channel
it lets us know what's working with you
guys so thanks a lot so this weekend saw
the six remaining teams at katowice vie
for the tournament's 400 000 grand prize
on lan at the spodeck arena but it's
always meant a lot more than just the
prize pool with everything that katowice
has contributed to cs it's almost like
it's the people's major and while the
team names were of course familiar faze
g2 navi
some of the lineups weren't faze clan
were forced to play the tournament with
jks as a stand-in first for rops during
the group stage and then for reign
during the playoffs both players had
positive coveted tests which prohibited
them from participating but as far as
i've heard they both seem to be doing
okay and while their aussie stand-in had
been without a job since the collapse of
the complexity roster kerrigan did a
great job of integrating him into this
lineup getting him doing whatever needed
to be done for the team to succeed
sometimes that was fragging but a lot of
the times between twists rops and brokey
it wasn't rops in particular had some
incredible moments under pressure the b
bomb site says we've stopped you here so
much in this comeback you have to go
back towards a but that's crumbling as
well ops is in a huge amount of trouble
he's gonna try and take matters into his
own hands couldn't find the second shot
fast enough but jax he drops in oh talk
about an estonian
superstar talk about the elite raps is
on a rope and we're going to overtime
baby instead jks had that most elusive
of stand-in performances
slotting into a roster and if you can
forgive my canadianism
getting or done bud
fast pace towards banana the play has
been called hunter's gonna turn that
corner jks has got him
huddled behind another flashbang from
kerrigan utility starting to be
impactful jks starting to be impactful
and this round is all but done and while
the grand finals box score says 3-0 it
was about the closest 3-0 that you can
expect in counter-strike inferno went to
overtime after faze recovered from a 15
to 7 deficit yeah after faze took map
one the two teams had to play 58 rounds
of mirage to decide it faze took that
one and closed it out with a 16 to 14
nail biter on dust 2. dimitri wherever
you are right now i hope you're doing
okay after watching so much mirage
anyways it was exciting counter-strike
and a reminder that as things begin to
open up and some of these new rosters
are tested
there's a lot of potential for surprises
in competitive cs phases brokey won his
first ever mvp award for his performance
at this tournament and if he can
maintain that level of play i think
phase could definitely be a podium
mainstay for the foreseeable future sure
there's a lot of firepower on this team
no one is denying that and they have
kerrigan a canny igl with a reputation
for exploiting teams in the map veto but
if you're a phase fan they've had both
these things before been there done that
instead it's not just that they have
great pieces again they've had those
before it's that they're fitting
together very well even in very
difficult circumstances there's a lot to
be excited about if you're a faze fan
but if you hear that little voice in the
back of your mind whispering the word
consistency i can't say i blame you and
their grand finals opponents also have
reason to hope g2 esports decision to
sign monacy pretty much speaks for
itself at this point the results have
been very strong and they defeated
virtus pro and navi on their way to
grand finals without dropping a map
pretty impressive stuff i'm not sure a
lot of people would describe the
decision to sign monacy as a gamble he
seemed poised to break out imminently
but at the same time putting a promising
prospect on your roster is absolutely no
guarantee of success in counter-strike
g2 esports showed great results at this
tournament and their rookie was an
important piece of that puzzle but even
more exciting is that this is just the
very beginning of monacy's story and
he's going to get to develop on a roster
with plenty of resources sitting next to
one of the greatest players in
counter-strike nico i'm a massive stan
of french cs and so the next thing that
i'm about to say will be deeply painful
but i don't think this roster has even
come close to touching their ceiling and
i think if they can continue to develop
they will be the best version of g2 that
we've seen so far i think there are
understandably some questions about how
this roster will develop particularly
with alexi b at the igl position their
map veto basically had them subsisting
on a diet of mirage inferno and dust 2
and they played all of those maps
against faze and they didn't win any of
them but with monaci and nico teaming up
on this roster it feels like this could
be the dawn of a new age for g2
mentioning monastery as well 16 years
old this is by far the biggest stage
he's ever been on how cool how
calculated how good was he in that first
map he's insane like i know it if he
gets a good start he will shine like i
know that the crowd will push him even
more like once he does some crazy play
like that he will just keep going like
he will not stop and he didn't stop on
the mirage at all so i'm really happy
that he put out such a performance i'm
really happy and proud of him finally we
have navi a team that struggled with
illness at this tournament but also
something more simple is quite frankly
the greatest counter-strike player ever
and he was playing this tournament while
his home country of ukraine was being
invaded by the russian military even
with his team racked by illness and the
tragedy unfolding across the border to
the east simple gave a historic speech
in support of solidarity and peace
between all humans and all of us want
peace
for ukraine and for whole world
all of us scared
and
we all need to stay humans first so
thank you everyone who came i hope you
will enjoy this tournament
listen navi reach semi-finals but i
think it's fair to say that this was not
their typical tournament they'll be back
they'll be hungry and it's quite
possible they'll be the final boss for
some time and the organization's
contribution to esports domestically in
ukraine has been substantial long before
astralis were eating pancakes with the
mayor of copenhagen
ukrainian players were getting blinged
out with watches from the ukrainian
prime minister in 2010. more recently
president zolensky congratulated the
team on twitter for their major win in
november and this is certainly one of
the only countries on the planet where
national leadership has been paying
attention to esports as zolensky said in
this tweet for decades so yeah while
many organizations have some sort of
legacy national affiliation that's
either played up or perhaps ignored
na'vi has been an important part of
ukraine for a long time and seeing
simple speak on the situation not only
moving but maybe a historical moment in
esports and as an aside from all of us
here at the score our heart goes out to
all ukrainians who are fleeing in danger
or are worrying about an uncertain
future as this conflict unfolds so what
did you guys think about katowice
personally i was hoping for a much
better performance from both heroic and
gambit but they both ran into phase in
the bracket so
can't feel too bad about that i guess
let me know in the comments below we'll
catch you next time
[Music]
you